[Music]
was that you must be new that is first
point
[Music]
that's away Clark Kent Daily Planet
what's your position on the bath Virgil
ante in Gotham civil liberties are being
trampled on their city people living in
fear thinks he's above the law the Daily
Planet
criticizing those who think they're
above the laws will hypocrite for what
yourself considering every time your
hero saves a cat out of a tree you're a
tough pieced editorial about an alien
gonna burn the whole place down most of
the world doesn't share your opinion mr.
Wayne
maybe it's Gotham City and me you just
have a bad history with freaks dressed
like clowns
boys hmm Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I
love it
I love bringing people together how are
we looks hi hello Lex it is a pledge ow
wow that is a good grip you should not
pick a fight with this person you know
the oldest lie in America senator
but power can be innocent
you're gonna go to war
some [ __ ] brought the war to us you
know you can't win this
it's suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world Son of Krypton
versus bat of Gotham you're psychotic
there's a three syllable word for any
thought too big for little minds Sam
you've learned what it means to be a man
you'll be dead already
man won't kill god
what have you done
he with you I thought yours with you we
as a population on this planet have been
looking for a savior we're talking about
a baliya whose very existence challenges
our owns and